well it seems each year hackers keep
getting smarter and there's more of them
problem is a lot of businesses don't
have enough good guys working the
keyboard
companies are struggling to fill
necessary cyber security jobs
a state of cyber security 2022 report
shows 46 percent of all companies have
understaffed cyber security departments
what can las vegas companies in this
very situation do to stay cyber safe the
biggest thing is just training up the
staff that you do have the number one
priority two-factor authentication which
means that if they're gonna be logging
into any accounts or systems or anything
like that you have your business that
there's a separate authentication that
happens those include a text message to
verify identity or an authenticator app
to log in a lot of these compromises
where businesses are losing money from
these different cyber criminals is when
there's emails that are getting sent out
my recommendation would be don't ever
send any account information any login
information via email another obstacle
some workers in-house some still remote
basically all you're doing is you're
increasing your you know your surface
area your the ways that people can
attack you from from a cyber perspective
for those companies that still have
people working at home make sure that
they're using a vpn or virtual private
network and make sure people you're in
contact with are people you actually
work with scammers call and act as new
employees or someone from a different
department before you put anything in an
email to somebody i would pick up the
phone and call even if you're struggling
to staff up your cyber team useful
information is readily available and can
be imparted to the team you have now
making sure
that your your employees have the
training that they need to not fall for
some of these common scams that are out
there
and for more tips on how to stay safe
online head over to our website eight
news now dot com click cyber safe parent
it's right under the news tab